hello I'm in a new location which means
that it's time to start freaking out in
Earnest so if you're not freaking out
already you better start freaking out
because everything is new and everything
is changing
[Music]
I'm about to start filming my movie if
you didn't know I'm filming a movie so
you now know it's been about a year
since in space with came out and I've
been cooking up a new project ever since
and I wanted to make something that was
going to be a little bit different than
what I made before and it's my first
attempt
I'm making a feature length
movie when they sell space a lot of
people were like wow Mark you gotta make
a movie and they you know since space
was basically four movies all in one
it is a different experience though it's
uh it's a lot of different applications
of skills that I've learned over a very
long period of time of making random
bullshits who uh getting to the point
where I can make this and it is not
random [__] it is actually going to
be I don't know they
I hope it's the best thing that I've
made yet I mean that's kind of how I
wish all my things go I kind of kind of
just approached something with like yeah
I'm just gonna try to make it as good as
it can be and then whatever it is what
it is at the end of the day but this one
is going to be
more official I just want to make
something good you know that's all I've
ever wanted to make is just I wanted to
make good stuff you know when I started
doing YouTube 10 years ago that was just
my whole Mantra is like I don't know how
to make anything
but I'll make it the best that I can and
so that's what I did now I'm here 10
years later you know filming in a big
old Sound Stage and a set is being built
and you know the crew is all working you
know similar stuff to happen in in space
but you know there's kind of a different
energy to it it's not going to be an
interactive thing I'm sorry to
disappoint
um
yeah no it's it's kind of cool all the
pieces coming together and all the
different thoughts that go into it you
know it's one puzzle to make an
interactive experience so you try to
loop back together
um but it's a completely different
experience to try to tell an extremely
cohesive story
um that is both entertaining and
hopefully horrifying it's cool I love
making [__] but the reason that this
video is probably called something like
uh need some help or I mean I don't want
to be a desperate Cry for Help like that
but you know just like need a little Aid
a little assistance would be lovely
um I'm gonna be very busy it's not even
just that like making it is going to be
very busy usually on set it's like 12
Day hours anyway
um but I'm fine with that uh because it
is what it is and I love doing it so I'm
more than happy to do it
um but I'm gonna need a little help
because there's so many other things
that are jumbling in the mix here on
this one month I don't know what it is
about March but every company in the
entire world that I ever work with was
like yeah you need to do all all of
these things in March and I'm like but
March is when I'm filming my movie and
they're like you you're just a YouTuber
yeah it's gonna be a little busy I'm
going to do my best to make regular
content when I can but don't expect
anything of any High kind of quality I'm
putting all of my high quality energy
into the movie and I'm going to try to
keep up with uh dense let's call them
dense just like me dense but not in a
dumb way you know in like a dense
muscular way a dense 10 minute videos
we're really getting back to the
classics you know back in the early days
10 minute videos once a day but 10
minute videos that's what I'm gonna try
to do so I need some help in terms of
I'm real I'm really uh I'm hitting the
bottom of the barrel here I'm calling in
all the favors every every last Reserve
thing I've had I need to know the name
of every Five Nights at Freddy's fan
game that I have not played yet I need
to know whatever is the most readily
available uh short horror game that you
guys want what is the most random
internet experience what is anything
there was never a time that I've enjoyed
having game suggestions or video
suggestions in live streams or videos or
comments like that I am opening the
floodgates now I don't care how you get
it to me over the next month I need it I
need it all Twitter social medias uh
comment sections ready like I need
people I do I just need them I know that
I've asked before for like a game
suggestion list and I know that someone
out there and I can't remember who is
like has compiled it and has been
keeping it and maintaining it all this
time and I know that they're watching
this and they're wailing and gnashing
their teeth like damn you mark how could
you betray me but now it's okay I'm
making a movie and that excuses anything
so yeah if you got an idea for something
I'm gonna tap into it because uh it is
kind of like requiring all of my like
creative attention I really can't wait
for you guys to see this much like I
can't wait for you guys to see all the
projects that I have
um and I didn't actually expect to be
jumping into another one just so soon
but I
it's
I mean you know me when I have an idea I
just kind of have to do it and
everything kind of kind of gets shunted
to the the sidelines it's not like it's
not like I I know that's not the perfect
right way to do it but I'm only just me
and I'm I'm only just the guy that likes
to make things so I'm just gonna have to
keep making things because that was that
that's what's making me because that's
what makes me happy
and that's what I'm gonna keep doing
because that's worth doing
um it's tough it takes a lot of work you
know it's not that I I don't love making
Gents
really hyper dense like the the
entertainment value is packed in there
like dense entertainment 10 minute
videos
um but I like doing it all you know I
like doing it all and I don't like to
give up on one to do another even though
it can like fall short sometimes just
know I mean you guys know this by this
by this point you guys know me like if
I'm if I'm quiet on one thing it's
because I'm working loudly on another
thing but where no one can hear me you
know if if Markiplier is making a movie
in the woods and no one's around to hear
it is the movie still gonna come out yes
um so I'm sure many of you have many
questions about like what is it what's
the movie will you make it I'll tell you
soon and then you're gonna be like well
oh the answers were there all along I'm
such a genius in my narrative uh yada
yada you'll know soon enough and it'll
be oh so surprising and it will be oh so
entertaining and I think you'll like it
a lot and I think um
I think when I'm done with it
I'll be very proud of it and then I will
be already rushing in to make the next
thing because this is kind of how I do
so look forward to something new in the
very near future probably this year
it's gonna be a fun time thank you
everybody so much for joining and
stopping by and listening to my words
and now you are updated on all the
things and if you can help me out in the
next month and a half or however long it
is
I would greatly appreciate it
thanks for being here and allowing me to
do these crazy things that I have
somehow still kept up doing
well somehow still been able to do them
I mean really I would still be doing
them it's just like people just allow me
to do these things and they kind of like
call back when I'm like all the crew of
space is like back on this one and it's
just like hey you guys want to work on
another crazy project and they all say
yes that is the most lovely thing
that I've ever experienced is that they
believe in me enough that they're
willing to put you know their time you
know on the line and and trust me that
it's like yeah let's do something else
let's do something else have some fun
and you know
that means a lot to me it really does
like
they're good people and they're good at
their jobs and
I don't know
just making cool stuff
it's a dream
I'm always gonna remember that so thank
you all right I'm gonna get out of here
before it's uh too long can't have the
um
algorithm thinking I'm keeping people
here too long
or something like that
how does the algorithm work
I've never really known